[Música]
i
ah
[Música]
el mes cantú es el paraíso de los
senderistas la naturaleza permanece
intacta gracias a este hombre
hola didier todo está bien cuando se
está en este paraíso hoy es séptimo el
descubrió el macizo del me jacto hace 66
años allí y su construir esta cabaña en
la que vive solo cada mañana lo primero
que hago cuando abro las ventanas es
contemplar las ardillas que comen no veo
otro lugar en el que pudiese estar más
feliz es la última foto que tomé el 17
de junio de 2019 es la número 122 1.083
la fauna de estas montañas fue el motor
de su compromiso con la creación del
parque nacional se pasó toda su vida
estudiando la y fotografiando la cada
mañana porque practica el senderismo
este es mi paseo alguna especie de
círculo necesito unas cuatro horas para
ello llega descubrió el misterio que
rodea el nombre de esta región según él
hay que echarle un vistazo a la
antigüedad madre cantor madre el marcan
el camino por la montaña y el padre es
julio césar démosle al césar lo que es
del césar regresemos le también a goya
este último lo que imparte le pertenece
la conservación del parque nacional que
miles de senderistas recorren cada año a
veces con la ayuda de robustos con grupo
dos
vamos avancemos este grupo de niza
alquilo estos burros por 40 euros
diarios y no se arrepienten y simpática
cambiarla
y está muy bien no tener que cargar el
morral y ello nos permite llevar más
cosas porque normalmente en senderismo
tratamos de limitar el peso y en esta
oportunidad tenerlas previstas una buena
cena para esta noche
dos horas después una parada para
desayunar y el primer balance en el
senderismo no hablamos mucho para
escuchar saber si hay sol hay muchos
venados pero durante la mañana hemos
escuchado sobre todo avanza avanza no
vimos ni la cola de un zorro hicimos
mucho ruido
el grupo arranca poco a poco y los
árboles desaparecen y pequeños gritos
invaden de nuevo la montaña son las
marmotas cantando
aquí
tras 900 metros de desniveles y 5 horas
de senderismo el alivio el lago de mil
fon perfecto para acampar
es una pequeña aventura durante un fin
de semana descansamos de la vida el
trabajo de todo lo que podemos y
regresamos del fin de semana recargados
con energía para iniciar una nueva a
unos 30 kilómetros más al este los
senderistas más cómodos cambian la carpa
por una noche de confort en el refugio
de las maravillas es uno de los más
frecuentados de francia cuántos somos
esta noche jefe 75 hugo es el guardián
del refugio de las maravillas desde hace
tres años sabe hacer todo incluso las
tartas calóricas que les gustan a los
senderistas
hay que dar de comer a los senderistas
aquí todo se hace a mano porque la
electricidad es escasa contamos con
algunos paneles solares no podemos usar
robots domésticos ni aspiradora todo lo
hacemos a mano mientras que el equipo
trabaja los senderistas descubren las
famosas maravillas que le dieron el
nombre al refugio estos grabados
rupestres a cielo abierto fueron
con rocas por pastores hace cuatro mil
años y vemos cabezas con cuernos
cuadrículas se trataría de la premisa de
la agricultura felipe mismo la
agricultura una concentración de dibujos
única en europa a esta altura el hecho
de tallar en una montaña no es exclusivo
de las maravillas la diferencia es que
en otros lugares los grabados son pocos
y tal vez solo para indicar direcciones
aquí se volvió un santuario tras haber
recorrido estos dos kilómetros cuadrados
llenos de rastros prehistóricos la cita
es en las maravillas para una buena
escena antes del inicio el guardián
reúne a su equipo
vamos muchachos reuniones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en cuanto termina el ritual la cocina se
transforma en un hormiguero en el que se
preparan y sirven productos de
agricultura biológica y locales que
constituyen el renombre del refugio
y el trabajo es duro pero los compartir
esos son gratificantes
el éxito del mercantil no se desmiente
cada verano más de 400 mil visitantes
vienen a recargarse en estas montañas
[Música]